in an attempt to rescue a small isolated
population of snakes from decline a few
male snakes from several larger
populations of the same species were
introduced into the population in 1992
the snakes reproduce sexually and there
are abundant resources in the
environment the figure below shows the
results of a study of the snake
population both before and after the
introduction of the outside males
in the study the numbers of captured
snakes indicates the overall population
size so let's look at let's look at this
at this study here the data from the
study so in 1989 they what they captured
a bunch of snakes the total snakes
captured but a small fraction of them
were juveniles it looks like about five
of the i don't know 19 snakes were
juvenile and we see that the total
population seems to be declining the
total snakes captured which they say is
a
is indication as an indication of
overall population that that is
declining and then they introduce the
males from the outside and then it takes
a couple of years but then the
population seems to increase again
so let's see what the questions are
describe one characteristic of the
original population that may have led to
the population's decline in size between
1989 and 1993.
so we can only theorize they haven't
told us a lot they have told us it's a
small population so they say small and
it's a small isolated
small isolated population so when you
have a small isolated population some
things can happen that are a lot less
likely than if you have a large
unisolated population for example you
might have actually i'll just answer it
right here you might have an uneven
distribution of males females so not
enough males
not
enough
males that's less likely to happen if
you have a really large population but a
small isolated population well you know
there's a chance that you could skew one
way or the other and if you not have if
you don't have enough males you're not
going to have enough reproduction
you're
you might have
too few
too few young snakes in their prime of
the reproductive age so two
too few
young
young reproducing snakes
reproducing
snakes and there could be a bunch of
reasons why this maybe happened maybe
there was some type of calamity that
happened you know in 1988 where a lot of
the young snakes died or some type of a
predator and so all the snakes that are
left are the ones that are older and
they're not as viable in terms of
reproduction but that's one possibility
there
you could have some type of it's a small
population you you could have uh because
of the lack you could have a mutation
that is just disproportionately showing
up in that population which makes it
less likely to reproduce
so
so
mutation
mutation
in
population
that makes it less likely to reproduce
you for the actual test you just have to
describe one characteristic and these
are all possible characteristics
then in part b they say propose one
reason that the introduction of the
outside males rescue the snake
population from decline so for part b
i'll do that right over here part b
well if you if you had not enough males
introducing males so it could
could rebalance
could rebalance
male female ratio
male female
ratio
it could have introduced some genetic
diversity so you don't have the mutation
could
introduce
introduce
genetic
diversity once again this is a small
isolated population those are triggers
in your head and say okay there might
not be a lot of genetic diversity there
introduce genetic
diversity
the introduced male snakes might have
been younger
so could
introduce
younger
younger snakes they didn't tell us
whether the males from the outside what
age there were but these are just
theories based on what they did tell us
that that's one of the possibilities and
once again you only have to describe one
so you could just say could have rebound
balance the male female ratio
and then part c
part c
describe how the data support the
statement that there are abundant
resources in the environment
well
you know if you just saw this data you
could have said well maybe one of the
reasons for even part a is that you
didn't have abundant resources but
notice when you introduce males from the
outside now all of a sudden the
population keeps increasing so the fact
that the population keeps increasing and
actually goes above where it was in 1989
well that's a pretty good indication
that you have abundant resources there's
nothing that's putting a ceiling on this
growth once you somehow fix the problem
by introducing these outside males
so i could say
population
population
keeps
growing
from 93 or especially from 95
1995 onward
onward wouldn't happen if we had limited
resources
wouldn't
have happened without abundant resources
wouldn't have happened
happened
without
abundant resources
abundant
resources
and we're done